[music playing]
You guys ready?
Yeah.
There you go, little buddy.
Dump them out.
It's so cute.
Just stay calm.
Let him go, let him go.
He wants to go to
the willow line.
Run, run to the forest.
Porcupine Chase was a lot
of fun, a lot more fun
having the kids with me out here
because for the kids, it's fun.
So that makes it
real fun for me.
Run away, little porcupine.
It's so little.
And cute.
OK, we got the
porcupine out of there.
And now we have
to accept the house.
Yeah, let's put some
sheet iron on the cabin.
That way, the next
porcupine come along
can't just eat it up.
[music playing]
OK.
Let's push against it like that.
Got rid of the
porcupine, now I want
to make sure any other
porcupine that come up
can't chew on the cabin
like this one was doing.
Don't drop it on your toes.
Oh, we're going to
put it right here?
Yeah, you can just
go all the way down.
[hammering]
There you go.
And then at the bottom.
Oh yeah.
Pound it all the way in.
There you go, you got it.
Oh, they're right there.
This is the best way for
me to bond with my children
because they learn a
lot and it's hands on.
And sometimes I
think in the city,
they can almost become
like they don't need me.
They have everything at hand.
Do you think a porcupine
can climb up this medal?
Mm-mm.
No way.
When they're out here
in the environment,
they can sense the danger.
And they're relying on me 100%
so they kind of become sponges.
They soak in all the
knowledge real quick
when we're in an environment
like this traveling.
And that's how they learn.
Get them out in the field.
Gonna do the last one.
And expose them to it.
And they learn the right
way to survive out here.
[hammering]
There you go.
I'm real proud of you guys.
We came in, we did our business.
When we leave, we
leave a better place.
I'm tired.
Yeah, me too.
Let's go get some rest.
No quills in the den.
[music playing]